Republicans putting the pedal to the
metal apparently to uncover more
evidence of potential Biden family
corruption House Republicans releasing
bank records exposing Hunters
questionable overseas business dealings
and a huge payday of 20 million dollars
that's right 20 million dollars the cash
flow stems from the first son's time on
the board of the Ukrainian Energy
company barisma and Joe Biden's time as
vice president Congressman James Comer
begging the media to ask the president
about it
I wish the media would ask the president
what exactly did your family do to
receive this right 21 million dollars at
the house oversight committee has proven
he just continues to say well that's a
lie that's not true we have their bank
records Maria hey bank records don't lie
that might seem like a hard sell because
the media is providing some cover to the
bidens Politico accused of being biased
after tweeting then deleting this take
on the Biden family bank statements
quote but the memo doesn't show a direct
payment to Joe Biden The Washington Post
fact check Department did a sneaky
little update to their Hunter Biden
laptop story after first son Confidant
Devin Archer blew a hole in the claim
that Joe didn't dine with a barisma
executive and NBC News is getting mocked
for claiming Biden's brand is being
tested like never before Jesse we've
come a long way from Republicans our
conspiracy theorists making up lies
about Joe and Hunter too well yeah of
course I got 20 million dollars but you
can't say that it went directly to Joe
Biden
the Russia hoax Trump had the same
answer for two and a half years no
collusion and the answer never changed
Joe's answer has changed 17 times and
the media isn't curious about why it's
changing
if you're a journalist and someone
continues to lie over and over and over
again and all of a sudden it used to be
a conspiracy and now it's okay if I have
dinner with the berezma executive for an
hour right what what is this guy hiding
we have no money from China up actually
it says you've taken six million dollars
from China and no my family has still
not taken any money from China well JP
Morgan says that six million dollars and
the media asks them about climate change
there's no curiosity because they know
the minute they ask the first question
the entire Biden presidency is shot what
is happening to the media what happened
you get the impression that everybody
knew this so it's no longer a big deal
but then when you actually asked about
it they said how dare you but then now
it's like oh yeah yeah but it's just
money everyone does everybody does it
especially the bidens they've been doing
it for 50 years and by the way that's
one rallying cry no direct payments
that's it get behind that one 21 million
dollars fight to bite and cut shell
companies and cronies uh uh the dozens
of phone calls the drugs the gun the
hookers the neglected grandchild the
lies but no direct payments we haven't
even gotten to we haven't even discussed
the war think about there is a there's
something going on here with Biden
obviously he was there the whole time
before this started we got a war and it
doesn't even feel like a war you know
what I'm saying it's not doesn't feel
like a war it feels like they do
something and then they do something and
they just it's basically just an ongoing
profit Center and I think that there's
something there that we have yet to
address that has to do with our
president
okay intriguing judge your thoughts uh
well just to take off what Greg just
said you know if the United States were
really interested in engaging in a war
and ending it which really is the focus
of any War it's to get in and get out
uh we should have been involved when
they were lining up the tanks on the
border we should have been involved when
we knew when we had information of what
was coming and we didn't and so what we
have are these payments that just keep
going through they keep going through
from the United States another few
billion another few billion and
everybody goes over there Nancy goes
over there and Jill Biden goes over
there and then Joe Biden goes over there
and and and Randy uh Weingarten goes
over there you know because she wants to
compare schools but that's that's really
not what I want to say this whole issue
of the 21 million dollars 20 million
dollars to uh you can't show that it
went into Joe's account you know what
that's like that's like a defense
attorney telling a jury in a murder case
the prosecutor did not have the victim
tell you that he's killed that victim
that I as a prosecutor should dig out
the victim from the from the ground
bring him in heaven testifies to kill
them there's something called
circumstantial evidence and when you put
all the pieces together of the
whistleblowers and the bank accounts and
the lies and the facts that there was a
laptop with emails that confirmed
everything else and the time dinner
meetings about which the Press lied and
then the Washington Post won't even
admit that they said the wrong thing but
while there was no record on the
schedule about that famous meeting in
Georgetown with the barisma executive no
record we didn't recognize the name now
Devin Archer comes out and said yeah he
was there for dinner for the whole time
he was the exact from Prisma I mean it's
ridiculous the Press is not doing its
job and in the end the American people
don't even need the Press anymore they
can see it for what it is Elizabeth
Warren sort of stepped into this a
little little bit perhaps of thorn in
Biden's side if we have that sound bite
could we played please
I always worry about the influence
Peddlers in Washington regardless of
party affiliation and we got to shut
down the revolving door we got to have
ethics rules that apply to everyone
what do you think of that Harold okay I
think she is consistent on how she's
concerned about this issue but I would
just say three quick things one or four
quick things Hunter has a lot of
questions to answer uh I've not seen
evidence and I've said on your show Dana
and I've said on this show two things
has to if two things are shown or one of
these two things and certainly a two are
shown I will be the first to say that
not only is there a problem to the
president for the president but the
Congress should begin to act as if
there's like there's a problem one is
there any evidence of Vice President
Biden in His official capacity receiving
a payment
second is there any evidence of Vice
President Biden or when he was in
elected office or in an official
capacity doing something to enable or to
help his son if one or two of these
things or one or both of these things
are true then Congress would be right to
begin an impeachment percentage finally
on the Putin thing in Ukraine you all of
my dear friends and I love you dearly
but I'm I'm for the United States I'm
not for Putin I know you're for the
United States as well but I'll remind
you of this if we allowed Putin to take
Ukraine without us providing assistance
and weapons and money to Ukraine China
would have take my theories China would
have taken Taiwan already and Putin
would not have stopped advancing across
Europe so I'm glad we're doing what
we're doing that you want to make
another point
the whole idea that you know you need
this information you need this direct
evidence what did Joe Biden do as vice
president and showed there was a problem
he withheld a billion dollars of
American money until a prosecutor was
fired we are involved in the highest
crime level in 30 years in this nation
have you ever seen Joe Biden once one
time with all the lunacy and all the
chaos and Anarchy in this country going
after one prosecutor in the United
States not a one but he could be damn
sure he's going to go after the
prosecutor in another country where his
son is on a board making a million
dollars a year and not only that he did
it as president when he didn't sanction
the woman who gave Bobby and a half
million dollars to his family also I
would say Joe Biden did benefit when I
don't I think it's pretty direct when
your grandchildren who aren't even a
voting age or getting thousands hundreds
of thousands of dollars in their bank
accounts that doesn't seem that seems
like a direct benefit but I don't I
don't think the Trump kids should
because they go into business and they
were in business when President Trump
was in office that they should be that
they people should say Well they're not
good business people because their dad
was in office that's why their their
numbers were what business is divided
they were all in business before that we
don't know what the bidens do but they
were they were lobbyists and Consultants
you may not think I hear you but
that's a felony yeah because he's an
unregistered it's not even the
consultant but now he's a
foreigner has questions to answer but I
think taking it from Hunter to the
president
maybe it's a bigger leap we're gonna go
coming up I thought we were over this
the media says you should start wearing
a mask in your own home
yeah hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else